allez on prend la direction de nous en
les fontaines à présent ou se tenait ce
week-end le sud torrent jumping festival
pour cette deuxième édition le concours
international de saut d'obstacle la
cueillait une centaine de cavaliers
leurs chevaux un spectacle de très haut
niveau comme sur les preuves du 140 qui
a suivi pour nous Faustine une autre
[Applaudissements]
le regard rivé sur le parcours un petit
public de connaisseur profite du
spectacle sous leurs yeux 49 cavaliers
leurs chevaux affrontent les uns après
les autres cette série d'obstacles à un
mètre 40 du haut niveau parmi eux
d'ailleurs une majorité de
professionnels y compris des médaillés
olympiques
dans les profs il était vraiment très
bien dans la 140 c'est un cheval qui est
destiné à sauter les gros Grand Prix
plus tard on changer un petit peu de
réglage sur le cheval ça on a essayé de
changer un peu de truc on fait de fautes
à la fin mais le cheval c'est assez bien
comporté ça évolue dans le bon sens le
cheval était bien la partie au
chronomètre on prend des risques et puis
on prend des risques plus on a de chance
de faire une barre donc c'est c'est ce
qui m'est arrivé j'ai tourné très court
sur un vertical où il la découverte au
dernier moment et on a fait une faute de
d'antérieur voilà c'est faute son
scrutés par un jury depuis deux ans le
sud torrent jumping festival est un
concours international alors comme la
règle le prévoit un juge étranger est
présent parmi les français pour
représenter la Fédération internationale
ce juge c'est Akram Bensalah tunisien et
passionné d'équitation on peut pas juger
un cheval tout seul et un cavalier tout
seul c'est un couple il peut avoir une
petite faute et parfois bon quand un
cheval est en forme c'est comme des
sportifs sont des sportifs quand il est
en forme et tout il peut faire un
parcours extraordinaire et peut faire un
ce qu'on appelle un sans faute espagnol
anglais Suisse français cette année 110
cavaliers et 246 chevaux ont concouru au
total sur les différentes épreuves des
quatre jours une réussite pour se
rassemblement qui prend de l'importance
donc on a de très bons chevaux
d'excellents cavaliers les cavaliers
olympiques
des cavaliers de coupe des nations
d'équipe de France des cavaliers
étrangers et on a les amateurs qui
courent le circuit de l'Amateur Gold
tour qui sont dans les meilleures
amateurs de France donc vraiment sur le
plan sportif on peut difficilement
espérer mieux samedi l'épreuve à 140
c'est terminé par la victoire d'un
couple tricolore Max tirouin et sa
jument utopie Villelongue une première
étape avant un Grand Prix ranking à 145
dès le lendemain